so your John D Rockefeller in the late
1800s and you have a big problem it's
the Industrial Revolution and you have
this giant oil Empire but you simply
can't find enough wage slaves to keep
the wheels turning unlike a day where
you can just make a job Post online and
a bunch of educated laborers will come
flocking your way back then most of
America was rule most of America lived
simple lives on farms they were
homeschooled they went to schools ran by
Churches they didn't know how to work a
factory job or at an oil refinery they
weren't conditioned to clock in and outs
so you needed a way to educate the
population on a massive scale so they
could come work for you however we don't
want to educate them too much now do we
remember knowledge is dangerous there's
a reason why slaves weren't allowed to
learn how to read or write so if you're
gonna educate the masses you have to
tread very carefully teach them too much
and they'll become too ambitious to
Independence they'll think for
themselves they'll become your
competitors instead you want to teach
them just enough so they can keep your
Empire running with a happy OB
so what did you do you helped pie near
the American public school system all of
a sudden every parent could just send
their kids off to a free public school
funded by Good Old Rockefeller to the
rest of the world you look like a saint
you were giving free education to all
those uncivilized ignorant Americans but
you and I know the truth by dangling the
prospect of free education in front of
millions of American parents you were
able to trick them into relinquishing
their children to the states that way
for 8 to 12 years of a child's most
formative years you get to condition
them to be exactly who you want them to
be you get to decide what they learn and
don't learn you get to decide how they
see the world you get to condition them
to be scared to be fearful to be
obedient to not chase after their dreams
to accept mediocrity you get to teach
them that if they don't follow orders
exactly to the T they are a failure I
can't believe it
because these are the traits that make
for a good laborer and it works by
giving every American access to free
standardized public education you were
able able to solve the labor problem in
America now every generation that came
after it would go into school filled
with innocence creativity and joy and
they would come out of school as an
obedient worker that doesn't want to
rock the boats workers who are perfectly
happy making their employers Rich
education system is predicated on the
idea of academic ability and there's a
reason the whole system was invented
around the world there were no public
sessions for Education really before the
19th century they all came into being to
meet the needs of industrialism ah yes
our entire education system today was
created because John D Rockefeller
needed more work
but it wasn't just Rockefeller now loads
of other Rich American tycoons poured
billions of dollars into creating the
modern day education system we have
today these are the same wealthy
dynasties behind Big Oil big food big
Pharma and they all wanted to provide
you with free conditioning I mean
education while they send their kids to
private schools as Rockefeller once said
I don't want a nation of thinkers I want
a nation of workers these are the dark
origins of our education system and why
you want to stay dangerous
for Generations experts tended to blame
failing schools on failing neighborhoods
but reformers have begun to believe the
opposite that the problems of failing
neighborhoods might be blamed on failing
schools I'd like for this country to
have a real education president for a
change I'd like to be the education
president I don't ever expect to sign my
name to any law that is more important
than the education I had in 1965. the
Day of Reckoning is here
if you watch this channel you're
probably serious about gaining money and
power which is great but if you're gonna
do that you're gonna need a great wallet
that can keep up with your Ambitions and
the wallet I've been using every single
day for the past three years is my extra
wallet extra is the smartest wallet out
there that has been seen on Forbes
hypebeast BuzzFeed and I absolutely love
mine it's got a quick access trigger
that is super satisfying to use you can
spend an hour just fidgeting with it
it's RFID blocking it's got a strap for
cash but my favorite part is that it
still looks really classy while having
all these features other minimalists and
smart wallets out there work but they
make you look really tacky whereas this
one is made out of real premium lwg
silver rated leather which is why too
this day I still get a ton of
compliments on it and as you can see
it's held up pretty well for over three
years of abuse the one I have is their
Senate model which is the one I
recommend it's got the perfect balance
and you can choose from a few different
leather colors I love giving these out
as gifts because nothing says I believe
in you more than giving someone a
high-end wallet for them to store all
the money they're gonna make in and for
a limited time get up to 25 off-site
wide when you shop using the links
shop.x3.com jaketran or use my code
jaketrain at checkout so pause the video
and get 25 off with the link below
thanks to extra for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
the origins of the American education
system can be traced back to something
called the Prussian Empire the Prussian
Empire is the Empire that made up modern
day Germany and these pressures were
Geniuses at controlling the masses see
in the late 1700s Prussia invaded Poland
and they won Prussia now occupied Poland
but the prussians now face a new problem
sure they controlled Poland but how were
they going to get the Polish people to
accept their new German rulers they were
the colonizers the enemy and yet somehow
they needed to get the entire population
to throw away their polish identity and
to accept Imperial German nationalism
but the prussians weren't stupid they
knew they had no chance in changing the
minds of the adults the adults were
proud Polish people they were set in
their ways there's no hope in converting
them but the children are the Polish
children were much more moldable and if
they could attack the children they
could decimate polish culture in just
one generation so Prussia created a new
eight-year education system where for
eight years kids would go to school and
learn things like reading and writing
but they will also also learn how to
listen to orders they would learn how to
do as they're told to respect the
authority of their Prussian leaders and
this new Prussian education system
worked one Prussian philosopher
brilliantly described their education
model by writing education should be
aimed at destroying Free Will so that
after peoples are thus schooled they
will be incapable throughout the rest of
their lives of thinking or acting
otherwise and as their schoolmasters
would have wished when the technique has
been perfected every government that has
been in charge of education for more
than one generation will be able to
control its subject securely without the
need of armies or policemen it was as
poetic as it was true basically if you
want a submissive population that you
can rule over you have to destroy their
free will you have to condition them not
to think thinking is the enemy and you
have to start this conditioning when
they're as young as possible so every
polish and Prussian child was required
to attend school for eight years eight
years were day in and day out these kids
were forcefred so much Prussian
patriotism that by the time they left
all obedience to the Prussian monarchy
was the only reality they knew the
Prussian system was so effective that it
caught the eye of one person an
influential American politician by the
name of Horace Mann and Horace man plan
on exporting this Prussian model to the
good old us of a
foreign
[Music]
was passionate about reforming American
Education it was his life's Duty so in
1843 he traveled across Europe visiting
schools to get ideas but no education
system impressed him more than the
Prussian model to him the Prussian model
was a work of arts here was the roadmap
to molding children into anything the
elite wanted if the Prussian model could
remove every single trace of Polish
culture what could it do for America
what the Prussian model it wouldn't
matter if kids were Protestant Catholic
black an immigrant Native American or
even atheists because we would be able
to permanently instill patriotism Duty
and work into all of them and what Horus
men's political influence tax-funded
public schools following the Prussian
model slowly started popping up all over
America and slowly but surely parents
teachers those in charge and society as
a whole started to accept the Prussian
model as the only sensible way to
educate the youth instead of one big
class schools were divided into separate
classes for kids of different ages Horus
also wanted mainly women to be the
teachers which is why women dominate the
teaching field today teachers were even
sent to Prussia to learn firsthand how
their system worked authorities bought
into the Prussian model so much that by
1864 Congress made it illegal for Native
American kids to be taught in their
native languages instead they were sent
to far away boarding schools so teachers
could kill the Indian to save The Man by
the end of the 1800s the Prussian model
had taken over America and by 1900
almost every American state made public
school mandatory meaning that you had to
give up your kid to the states or get
the kid taken away from you and thrown
in prison Horus Manchester changed the
face of American public education
forever but the public school system
wasn't in its final form yet because as
much as the Prussian motto did wonders
for the government it still didn't do
much for businessmen like you and as
John D Rockefeller you also saw the
power of Oppression model on the masses
and you plan on systematically
infiltrating its
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
by the late 1800s school was mandatory
they were using the Prussian model but
there was still a giant problem there
wasn't any standard curriculum to follow
so most kids ended up learning nothing
that would make them useful in an oil
refinery mine or factory it doesn't
matter how submissive or obedient they
are if they don't have the Baseline
education needed for your labor you
needed submissive obedient workers that
were also educated to your standards
educated on how work will set them free
so what did you do you went to your
closest Confidant a man named Friedrich
T Gates and together the two of you
created the general education board on
the outside the general education board
sounded like this very official
government board that looked over the
education system in America and that's
exactly the vibe you were going for when
in reality you just created this thing
of the nearer and named it the general
education board that is the power of a
great name and a year later thanks to
your Connections in Washington the
general education board went official it
was incorporated by an act of Congress
in 1903 with the purpose of the
promotion of education in the United
States of America without distinction to
race sex or Creed a very Noble sounding
cause while at the same time this thing
this entity would be your Trojan Horse
to inject one of 3.5 billion dollars in
today's money into the public school
system today a few billion dollars
wouldn't make a dent in the monstrosity
that is our Public School System but
back then it was still in its infancy so
3.5 billion dollars was way more than
enough to mold it into whatever you
wanted so with the money and the
government Charter in hand the board
went on to fund a vast number of public
high schools 912 high schools in the
southern states Alone by 1914. you also
funded universities medical schools Ivy
League schools so that when kids
finished their conditioning in high
school they would continue their
conditioning in higher education these
are the origins of America's love affair
what college degrees by the way college
graduation has never been more valuable
than it is today and soon other business
tycoons started jumping in on the action
by 1905 Andrew Carnegie the steel
magnate founded the Carnegie foundation
for the investment of teaching not
because he wanted people to learn about
the world and become innovators but
because he needed mind managers
operators Engineers repairman smelters
and railroad conductors and the public
started to catch on on all this big
money moving into education in 1914 the
National Education Association said that
we deal with the Lord the activity of
the Carnegie and Rockefeller foundations
agencies not in any way responsible to
the people and their efforts to come
our state educational institutions to
Fashion After the conception into
standardize our courses of study and to
surround the institutions with
conditions which men is true academic
freedom but your infiltration of
Education had picked up too much steam
too much momentum there was no way it
was going to slow down now by 1918 every
single state started requiring kids to
complete Elementary School and it just
picked up from there from standardized
tests to the Carnegie funded textbooks
to the Department of Education to
labeling and medicating kids that don't
do well in this Rockefeller motto of
education and your boy Friedrich T Gates
who you created the general education
were with put it perfectly when he
explained what he envisioned for
America's education system in our dream
we have Limitless resources and the
people yield themselves for perfect
hostility to our molding hand the
present educational conventions fade
from our minds and unhempered by
tradition we work our own Goodwill onto
a grateful and responsive rule folk we
shall not try to make these people or
any of their children into philosophers
or men of learning or of science we are
not to raise up among them authors or
writers poets or men of letters we've
shown a search for embryo great artists
painters musicians nor will we cherish
even the humbler ambition to raise up
among them lawyers doctors preachers
Statesmen of whom we now have ample
Supply
education system Rockefeller wanted one
that didn't search for the intrinsic
gifts and doubt in each of us one that
didn't pump out philosophers authors
artists or musicians no our modern day
education system was designed for one
thing and one thing only to pump out
mindless thoughtless standardized dare I
say it slaves John D Rockefeller put it
even more succinctly he said I don't
want a nation of thinkers I want a
nation of workers and iffy look around
today with all the sphere all this debts
all these years of education and yet you
come out not even knowing the basic
fundamentals of how to survive in this
world like how to find a lifelong
partner save make money invest and file
taxes when you look around to see all
this I'd say like Rockefeller got
exactly what he wanted
so now that you know that Society is
systematically designed to get you to
slave away forever how do you escape
this you escape it by finding a way to
make a lot of money without having to
work super hard like all the other
docile workers and the most practical
way to do this is not what you think the
most practical way to do that is with a
high paying work from home job there are
work from home jobs out there that allow
you to make eighty thousand dollars
ninety thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars and up while working
just a few hours a day from wherever you
want but the reason why you never hear
anyone promoting work from home jobs is
because pitching you on starting an
agency or whatever sounds a lot sexier
but the reality is although all those
business models work you gotta grind it
out for 12 hours a day seven days a week
with a very low chance of success that's
why most entrepreneurs end up slaving
away more than someone with a 9-5 but a
work from home job you get the best of
both worlds the reward without the risk
the flexibility without the ground and
in some cases you can even make more
money than with the business by stacking
war from home jobs on top of each other
without increasing your workload also
known as overemployments but the best
part about work from home jobs is that
truly anyone can land one problem is how
do you land one without a degree or
experience luckily I figured it out see
before YouTube I landed a 40 per hour
work from home job at just 19 years old
without a degree and barely any
experience that's eighty thousand
dollars a year at just 19. from home and
this work from home job changed
everything for me it set me up to be
where I am today and the reason I was
able to go remote without a degree or
experience was because I came up with
really Innovative strategies that
drastically increased my odds of getting
hired and I break it all down in our new
masterclass called exploit the system
with over 90 plus lessons in the same
binge-worthy documentaries style you've
come to love exploit the system is the
best course out there on going remote
because not only did it work for me at
19 but it's also worth for our students
like Alex K who landed a 25 digital
marketing job while living in South
Africa where 25 an hour is the
equivalent of making around 75 dollars
an hour in America and he did it in just
40 days or take John S John was
struggling with interviewing for work
from home jobs but after going through
the master class well I was able to land
my first work from home position with
higher pay equity in the company and
many other benefits and quotes I
followed up with John less than a year
later and this is what he had to say
quote I was actually just promoted to a
Solutions engineering world this week
and the company just entered a merger
deal for over a billion dollars so I'm
being bought out of my Equity at seven
dollars a share from the two dollars a
share when I joined in March and it has
also opened doors at other SAS companies
such as stripe can't thank you enough
for the amazing course and value that
you provide End quotes the reason why
this master class is so effective is
because everything we go over is
extremely unorthodox to everything they
teach you and it covers everything you
need to start from zero we cover which
Warframe job would be the best fit for
you we cover the fastest way to learn
your work from home job from scratch but
where it really gets juicy is when we
cover my unique strategy that allows you
to instantly show that you have
experience without actually having
experience we then go over how to craft
an irresistible resume that will make
employers stop dead in their tracks
ignoring everyone else's resumes then we
go over how I have my phone blowing up
with offers thanks to my strategy for
applying to work from home jobs we go
over how to crush job interviews even if
you're shy nervous like I was and so
much more so that you can go remote as
fast as possible in this world you can
either be a docile worker like the
system intended you to be or you can
game the system and achieve a quality of
life that is 99.9 better than the rest
of the world so if this sounds
interesting to you click the square on
the screen or click the link below and
buy the exploit the system masterclass
now it only costs a tiny fraction of
what our students Alice and John made
from their war from home jobs and
there's a no questions asked 14-day
refund policy just email us so click the
square on the screen to buy now
[Music]